et bien c'est très rare
[Musique]
mais ce taux chimiques
ouais
cyril monsieur cyril temps les conti là
il va falloir revoir tout le monde doit
faire une sorte de flash mob tous
ensemble tu peux nous expliquer alors on
leur fera tout d'abord c'est simple je
vais leur faire promet steps et le
cercle d'amis la vente mais le point
comme ça voilà vous pouvez l'ouvrir
comme ça c'est simple photo sur place a
commencé à et accent circonflexe comme
ça on met les mains en triangle isocèle
à la corsa et on saute paille comme le
premier voilà et le dernier s'est
attrapé le bonheur on attrape à gauche
n'aura pas droit on crie allez 7,8 à
l'airé à aller aller voilà 2 1
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à voir la
bouilloire la banane le sourire bossa et
c'est un web
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à vous amuser
ou pas alors on va essayer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici à toi
[Musique]
un nouveau bouton nouveau né ouais
niveau skill avec un bonnet rouge
l'autre je vous ai trouvé ça ou si elle
est bonne est qu'on a eu en la poignée
il adore mais chéquier encore il a dormi
sous des bonnets de costumes chasse et
quand on fait c'est quoi le fruit
préféré des poissons ouest on mangerait
détruit non mais leurs fruits préférés
ils ne mangent pas mais c'est lorsque
préféré sexuelle de toute façon ça peut
être qu'un truc sexuelle entre comme ça
c'est la pêche
[Musique]
fort mentalement du coup la tâche mais
soir qu'elle serpent à une jambe le bois
parce qu'il a une jambe de bois
fais ton adversaire de emi les meilleurs
mais qui ose llc qui est mini c'est la
maquilleuse dit mchugh linceul the who
rien est assez simple
à la meilleure
ces marchés cadreuse en chef ou quand
même parce que des gros plans dans
l'émission voyez que 10 de biscottes
quand elles veulent aller danser
on va en discothèque
mais oui
[Musique]